foreign
by the way Nate's a great comic watch
his new special on Amazon killer we have
to plug if we're gonna show Hello World
great show Mark farting on him watch it
today okay by the way directed by
homeless pimp which is very impressive
Mike glavin we should give his real name
as well oh yeah celebrity theater
more you
[Music]
know
oh look at the eyes the head shake oh
not even a hit nothing happy there no he
looked like my dad when I said it was
gonna be a comic
brutal man I've only got 10 years I know
but he was in the middle of a story I
think it adds to the frustration when
he's trying to have a poignant moment
and you fart on him I guess so
well you had left I felt like it was
lacking a little ahead I took it up I
was here I think I would have saved it
because I didn't laugh I mean I'm
laughing just at the playback I need you
there I know I would have loved I have a
dream
that all farts are created equal I mean
uh pretty great dude I was in Vegas all
weekend I went I went off oh yeah well
you gotta go off it's Vegas oh I I went
hard I mean I don't know if you have
that picture of me Syracuse on my
Instagram yeah oh yeah we hit it hard
you you you playing uh looked like
blackjack with a cigarette and an old
sea cat I can even show you yeah oh my
gosh should I send you the the video I
guess doesn't matter my room was dude
that guy ruled he was 78. wow and he was
putting the drinks back and we hit it
off he was enjoying my Antics I was piss
drunk it's funny when your face is all
over the casino and you're still the
worst behavior there's just literally
posters of me all over and uh because I
was playing the Mirage and then I just
loaded at the table piss drum just you
know zapping cigarettes and after every
Blackjack hand I lose I start calling
the dealer a Nazi sympathizer and this
old guy's like losing it laughing so you
know all I need is a little laugh
something further I'm like a Hitler
Hitler
Hitler that's great hit Hitler again and
they're getting furious at me I can see
I can see the security like do we do
something yeah but uh no he was great
wow what is this oh that was Casino
take it back this is you at the table
which hand do you jerk off with
no both of them
take it back
a beaut
yeah [__]
[Music]
yeah I should say I was tipping though
which helps I'm a Hitler but I was I was
tipping money someone I posted that I
did that and someone wrote like well
yeah that's good you lost cause you know
you uh that's Karma and I was like well
I didn't lose although this is classic
comic [__] I was so shit-faced I was
down a decent amount of money for a
minute and then I noticed people stopped
paying attention to me yeah so I was
like hey guys I'm putting all my money
oh my God he's putting his money on I
was like man I'm a [__] yeah but I won
that hand thank God that was like 300 on
a hand whoa
hey all right yeah so I won I won the
money back I was doing like 25 a hand
but then I was like oh I gotta I gotta
go all in if I'm still gonna be the
center of attention
that's what it's worth you always see
the movies they're at craps tables the
girls blowing on the dice you know your
high-fiving everybody but it's never
that it's always four in the morning
with the old white haired guy oh dude he
was awesome and then the end of the
night he was like don't smoke you know I
uh I've smoked my whole life out like a
Planet Fitness like super Mr Universe
type guy and uh you know it cut 33 of my
oxygen I was like this is like a movie
whoa he was like I made every wrong
mistake I was like Dad
speaking of dad uh we got in the house
this week
his son he got divorced Syracuse has got
the baby
Kramer versus Kramer in the place yeah
love it yeah I I was joking with cell
because I go hey we'll see you today and
he goes ah you said tomorrow and I was
like oh he's like I got I was like well
bring him I didn't think he would pick
him up yeah you called my bluff and this
poor kid's out of school
what good influences drinking in the
afternoon yeah we should introduce one
of our guests bartenders here Shane hey
Shane pleasure what's shaking fatty
nothing much I'm from Colorado just
moved to New York about five months ago
whoa we're in Colorado oh Colorado
Springs hey a breakdown big navy base
right Naval bases Fort Carson so it's
Army largest base in territory-wise in
the whole country am I nuts or is black
klansmen set in Fort Collins it takes
place in the springs yeah spring sorry
why don't you work out we gotta focus on
the family of people who hate abortions
out there yeah well we'll still clear
I've had I've paid for a few yeah all
right well hey good to have you in the
spring how about a cocktail yeah yeah
I'm Jones
Oh I thought we do Manhattans but I
could do an old-fashioned oh I might
have [__] that up what whatever you
guys prefer I can make what are you
thinking let's do a Manhattan yeah
vermouth back here we must yeah hey all
right we got vermouth I like on the
Flies I like the chain out of the gate
any do you have any peeves anything
bother you in general
[Music]
[__] off what do you like yeah I get
that that bugs me you know what happened
to me last night I'm in my moons uh you
know right next to the cellar because
it's a Monday the band's playing it's
two packs I'm like I'll eat next door
I'm in moons alone this guy sees me he
comes in he goes Sam what bar do I go to
and I was like excuse me I don't [__]
know you I don't know what kind of bar
you like you know like that's you from
the past what bar should I go to so I
don't end up like this
uh yeah I don't know what'd you say off
the wagon I was like I don't know what
kind of bar you like he's like anything
I think I said peculiar Pub because I'm
like that's a cool Village Pub you get
600 beer choices yeah that's not bad
choice but he corned me in a way that
was I was kind of like all right is this
guy gonna he also had like the faux hawk
and was kind of intense I was like is
this guy gonna swing on me yeah because
that's the village now is dude I'm with
Ryan Hamilton we're walking around and
dudes are just in our face at the point
that it's crazy I got into it with a guy
I think I told you about that I'm not a
tough guy but this guy goes uh it was me
and a friend friend who had a camera
like a nice camera like that and he goes
where you going with that camera [__]
and I was like I just had a bad day and
I was like [__] off and he goes what'd
you say and he goes I've been to jail I
was like that's not a good thing so now
we're going back and forth and I see
Sean Patton walk up and I'm like all
right I got some backup so I just go in
on the guy and we're like face to face
and then the seller bouncers walk over
and I'm like whoa baby I am in the clear
Patton pulls out a knife and I was like
I gotta go on yeah hey there we go we
talked about this the knife's not you
don't want to be the doo-doo stabs true
yeah but you know what if the guy's
stabbing him
I think mace is the move because you can
you can get them down and get away but I
had my hand on the mace last night the
guy was really comes in the [__]
sandwich shop and starts me and Hamilton
are in Wolf nights I I had two dinners
and uh I was hungry and uh John Pinette
just dinners I uh we're in there and
he's [__] with the woman in there so
we kind of we're kind of like hey stand
down I said stand down that's pretty
good he was drunk you know but if you
guys pissed drunk I'm like I'm like
stand down and he was just like oh he's
oh my God [__] so now I'm his attention
yeah and I was like are you okay I was
trying to be like heroic and she's like
yeah I'm fine she's like used to it she
works in the village but uh behind my
hand of the mace and Hamilton was like
thank God you had the mace just in case
you know so where was it on you now no
it's in my jacket whoa oh I'm pumped
thank you sir let's see what we got that
looks nice we need a third for when uh
our guest judge gets here guest judge oh
yeah we have a guest judge this week
Simon's coming in yeah it's our video
last week where we trashed this Botox
there we go thank you Shane's my
pleasure you want one
you want a cocktail kid let's start him
slow give him a daiquiri there you go
maybe uh
that might be the best Manhattan we've
had from any from any guest judge I have
to say I don't normally like Manhattan's
up I like it I like I like a big round
cube in them but uh yeah this might be
the this might be the best Manhattan
we've had yet it's good because it's
subtle but flavorful at the same time
that is damn salad you want to get in
here yeah Shane first what's your
favorite Patrice O'Neal bit oh Jesus
Christ I like the one where he says um
the only reason we have sex is to save
[__] up to jerk off to later wow
yeah well done sir that's good Colorado
is he one of your who are your favorites
I'm a huge Bill Burr fan so that's a
good one extension I like Patrice sure I
love his bits on life
what's that talk show uh Opie and
Anthony oh yeah classic boy this
pro-lifer's all right
this is insane very good what's your bar
experience I
um so I ran a few cocktail bars back in
the springs
um I've been in the industry my whole
life so you know serving tables all that
[__] and then when I turned 21 I was
like oh this is the coolest job in the
restaurant so to learn how to bartend
bought some cocktail books and pretty
much stop myself random Japanese
speakeasies so a lot of Japanese whiskey
experience
um then from there we opened a cocktail
bar called The Archives
um still there today but I left it
behind to come out to the big city hey
hey
those guns yeah yeah you're [__] big
look at that guy I've gotten a little
chubby since I came out here the food's
too good man yeah it's pretty good
ridiculous this guy's got arms I know
look at that he could throw out some
some guests if we need to
certainly have to
all right
that was quick
oh good look at you I brought my I
brought my judge hat all right well he's
number one this is Shane at the bar
Safari how are you what's going on are
you gonna abandon us for Southeast Asia
oh that's what the beer Jew did for
context
howdy cowboy how are you guys I think
I'm excited for you to try this
Manhattan this is one of the best
Manhattans I've ever had too much he's
pretty good this guy's got the skills
are you guys checking this podcast and
the buys you guys
we'll get your sweatshirts now we'll get
you oh yeah that's a nice uh salmon move
okay Harold and Mom Harold them off
yeah he's back now
cheers boys all right
hey
these are the worst glasses to Cheers in
or just serve I prefer Manhattans and
nose glasses yeah they're sucker only to
the what's the straight out ones I don't
think
whiskey I don't think whiskey belongs in
a martini glass it's too it's too manly
a drink a martini I understand I hear
what you're saying it should be like it
should be in a cup type of thing
yes yeah I like in the old range they
wouldn't have had these on the Range
yeah the whiskey was John Wayne ain't
drinking out of one of these absolutely
not he's gonna shoot you in the gut yeah
he's busy dying of butt cancer he's not
gonna drink
what do you think Ari I think it's good
it's got a smooth taste to it I assume
this is an amarino cherry
no yeah
damn I knew that what is it so they're
actually they're called maraschinos but
it's a cherry from Italy Sebastian
Maraschino you really made a fool out of
me this new bartender yeah
I really threw it right you made a fool
out of yourself
so what's shaking how are you doing
doing good doing The Beacon Theater
March 24th
joining the club that's why you wanted
to come on I'm about to leave for six
weeks I got a long tour I'm not gonna be
back to promote it you did it Tim Dillon
did it Nikki Glazer just become a comedy
club I know it's the creek it's yeah
yeah it's the new Creek I should tell
you don't get paid wait what I'm kidding
Creek
set of business
um you do get paid those theaters they
say you get [__] money unless you do two
yeah somebody says that I'm just doing
one blowing it out yeah laid off the fly
or uh
Hometown get up there beautiful maybe or
walk oh yeah to the park up there back
then I lived walking distance so I I
walked so wow look this is what Jerry
probably does you got that right I heard
uh I heard a um
some of the old guys the Bruce Bruce
Lenny nope Springsteen drives to his
gigs in New Jersey just drives get out
to himself takes his guitar
he's like hey I'm here I get everybody
drives a ratty car too yeah yeah some
beater
this was in the movie Philadelphia
I just heard an amazing Bruce
Springsteen story that was on a podcast
about The Clash
um and Joe Strummer in 1975 saw
Springsteen play the Hammerstein
Ballroom in London yep and he was with a
little band called The 101ers and he
said I've started a new band he saw the
show he's gonna have to start a new band
have to be on my own
and also Peter Gabriel was in that
audience too what he left Genesis and
said I have to start a new solo career
because of that both saw that
Springsteen show and said wow wow I hope
you don't see that then I'm out
I want to see Louis at the Garden how
was that great Adrian kill Adrian
palucci's one of the best underrated
also that style it's like I've never
done a place like that have you guys
Arena it just seems like the the Styles
don't go with every style of Comedy
totally conversational is like it seems
like it'd be lost here and Adrian these
dark just jokes
wow look at that color the dark queen
she is a dark queen
she's got one of my favorite jokes of
all time where she said uh I'll say uh
my boyfriend threatened to commit
suicide now I thought oh great I can't
kill myself or people gonna think we
were in love that's a perfect job you
can't top that joke yeah yeah my my my
my ex was in um was in 911. people say
he's a hero but would a hero steal back
an engagement ring wow
that one's true
I'm like that's funny ironically oh it's
not ironic oh cool did she do the MLK
chunk because that's pretty dicey she
did and it was great yeah she Compares
MLK to Ted Bundy I won't give it away
but it's uh it's killer I think in an
arena or a big room like that dark
material actually does better I agree
really because they're like go for it if
it's a guy like Louie if it's it's a if
he's crazy as an audience that can
appreciate a dark joke I agree I think
the dark show can really Crush oh yeah
because they're like geez so you get
like a double reaction you get a laugh
Anna ah yeah what shock at telling that
type of joke it was in such a historic
Arena talk about wanting more New
Yorkers to die more parking yeah it was
just like wow they're showing it on the
pay-per-view just saw he said like yeah
I can see that Adrian said oh great wow
[__] which is awesome yeah good it was
fun though a couple that chick from
brown bunny was there
oh she's fun yeah the one of the two um
uh South Park guys
on to the brunette the brunette and I
couldn't imagine Matt Stone and I was
like where is that is it from like
Saturday basketball you know when you
know something where do I know this guy
yeah I want half of the greatest comedy
dudes yep we got [__] Conor O'Brien
Conan slow Brian yeah dude you look so
much like Conan have you gotten that I
have yeah okay I get Conan quite a bit
because you know I throw the hair up and
yeah there you go Irish what are you
gonna do that's a good one this is good
Manhattan um yeah can we do another
what's the next round what's the other
round we're doing
oh good call yeah I heard the lights
so does that mean we need another yeah
yeah sure sure have you ever done a
Godfather my house drink I have
he knows it my house my house drink if
we drank it on his pod you didn't love
it you thought it was so sweet old man
drink ultimate old man oh sweet
you like them I did yeah I was [__]
bombed dude
we went out for dinner afterwards we're
just like ah you guys a nice dinner
yeah we thought it was a good idea to
get Martini drunk after showing up drunk
yeah just ripped let's roll it that was
enough going do martinis get you hard I
had to chew before but the keys before
for a burger before Louie's two martinis
and you were [__] up how is it how's
the Burger Kings amazing
Burgers they're underrated yeah that you
think you gotta get a steak right but a
25 Burger is also a good thing to get
that's true it's too expensive though it
is and you would you walk out of there
with what 300 bucks spent no because
there's burgers or 50 maybe 120. okay
but also you it's the experience I mean
that is like a legendary New York place
the vibe is beautiful and everyone see
Louis retirement set at the Garden how
was the set so that was really good I
heard it's good he's like I'm not
retired I was like I was like dude I
don't know if I can be friends with you
anymore if you're not gonna be a comic
is he doing the Tarantino [__] he said
he's taking one full year off and then
we'll see I don't believe that he'll pop
everyone comes back yep our egos are too
big you turned my card table story yeah
exactly it's your card table oh I just
people weren't paying attention to me
for a second at the casino at the Mirage
so I just put all my money on a hand
like look guys look yeah we need
attention we do I would say the same
goes for therapy you know you can tell
your therapist is getting a little bored
you're like I killed my dad you know
just to get it going
make Ari The Godfather because it's not
my favorite I liked it but it's just not
my favorite I wanna I want your hits
anything's a better father than Matt
salick
and you're doing
people say do it with a blood and Scotch
but I'm like that's for bars yeah treat
somebody well
sorry if this was his swan song uh Louis
swan song was it is he going out on top
it was great but in the round at the
Garden yeah it was great his closer was
[__] so good let me do every bit from
it
yeah he's not gonna use it anymore
that's true 25 bucks they're on his
website it was fun I was sitting next to
Shane he was not drinking what a [__]
wow really what happened all right he
said he got tuned up the night before
and he's going to the Eagles game the
next day yeah it's very reasonable a
night off yeah let an alcoholic recover
dude so we so so where are we all these
backstage Delta Club passes for
afterwards to say hi you know and so and
so we're waiting for like an after party
type thing more of a come say hi in The
Green Room it was like lasted for an
hour yeah
um
that's where I saw everybody but uh so
we're waiting like let's let everybody
clear then we'll go down there and some
ushers the guys guys take gonna take off
and Shane's like tries to play big man
he swears this doesn't happen like this
but it did he goes oh no actually we're
going to the Delta Lounge we have passes
so I think I was like I don't give a
[__] who you are you gotta get out of
here
oh yes sir
I think that's how we all pretty much
are yeah I think we all we all see
ourselves the first way yes but we are
the second one whatever you need I'll do
I'll do she's gonna sweep up that's
pretty that sounds like a fun night hey
I got a joke I don't know how to sell it
all right let's do that in this podcast
okay so he's just here's the setup you
guys are the [__] wordplay guys
so if look two things one is uh after
after a game of some kind like the
cleanup is tremendous crazy yeah all
these cups or whatever so I say release
a couple of these [__] Asian women
out there
that's great with the cans yeah and then
step two take that to that garbage
island over the in the ocean like how
are we gonna launch some of them out of
a [__] helicopter with some life vest
on and let them [__] I thought you're
gonna say let them make the change money
for it that was a dark twist at the end
but I mean let him pick it up yeah I
love it yeah okay something's there
something there for sure yeah they would
love that too because they don't have to
go all over Manhattan they can just go
right to the golf shop yeah
you sell tickets to get the cans yeah
exactly yeah they're Farmers the right
to work this like like a barbershop
chair right I think you got something
there those Asians
determined unbelievable
you'd think I mean I sound like my dad
here but just put that effort into any
other gig but yeah but then now you got
hours you got a punch clock yeah you got
a boss exactly you're on times you're
working bottle Duty I think it's the
same with the hookers they don't want to
be here oh yes at which grocery stores
have that um yeah have what hookers
can I critique this Godfather
wait is it out yet oh yeah you got one
but did you not have enough orange peels
to make it right oh yeah I told you it
was coming
Jewish Simon
[Music]
we need that uh that America what is
this millionaire wife what is it called
uh Who Wants To Be A Millionaire oh
thank you wow that does look pretty nice
so what do we do yeah around two so it
sounded like you guys had drinks listed
um should we do paper planes let's do a
plan where'd you come from what's your
background Colorado from Colorado yeah
can I say it in Spanish
I like it I like it just moved here five
months ago you're so new to the city
yeah how do you know about this podcast
it was just uh of this podcast I like
are you garbage that's kind of how I
found out about marketing uh
I just saw those guys today
I wanted to feel special what if you did
a bam bam I wouldn't have felt this
special yeah exactly they did mine
can we do two I'm like no I have a
bigger thing going on yeah
I'm excited to have them on that's gonna
be a good one yeah that's good I think
it's a St Patty's episode too oh you got
that right that's smart hey can I come
back in here with stavi at some point I
have a fun time at that wedding no holy
[__] yeah and he was so it was so
[__] good we can bring in uh uh
catfish po boys and [__] go for it
yeah soft shell crab from a gas station
yeah you know it that was insane like I
felt so
shitty the next day and stuff just kept
going with the Po Boys yeah he's an
animal but he wasn't drinking like we
were that's true I'm doing Athens Greece
yeah what European tour I'm doing all
weird cities so I can have some fun wow
do you think you can sell tickets in
Greece we'll see your career is in Ruins
I don't pay taxes there I go home with a
lot more money hey that's nice um I'm
gonna get all the whole [__] thing
from stuff maybe I'll try to convince
him to come
he's got his own [__] going on he's
killing me he's just like five wilburs
yeah killing it
his new pot is funny as hell yeah oh
yeah very funny solves your problems
yeah
yeah fat comedians are having a moment
yeah they're taking more of the screen
it's good for that it's good for the
thumbnail yeah I think if you see it you
gotta get Matt Peters on a podcast
how do you not click that he's adorable
I know look at that hey what's that
reminiscent of he looks like Dennis
Franz Bobby's World Bobby's World yeah
absolutely okay I don't think the people
at home know Dennis Frost no they don't
I said that on this podcast
that is what
is one of us all right
what are you guys been doing what's new
in the [__] world it's like me doing
the beacon March 24th let me throw this
out there so I just did Miami Improv
boo to the city the city is fine the
people are fine the staff is amazing
stuff's amazing great Club they treat
you well they gave me a gift after they
couldn't have been nice so they helped
me with merch they drove me home every
night but the crowds they show up late
they show up late they're better than it
yeah so Jay and I had this problem I was
like I'm not doing it but I was like you
know what let me go with Jay and Justin
silver we went to the beach house stayed
there for a week
but it's great
um Mark and I fly out the next morning
at 7am you got that right it's [__]
winter go to Miami anyway yeah I'm going
to March so these two girls Jay's
hitting on these two girls and he's like
hey so what are you what are you doing
what's going on they're like we like you
but that other comic book was an [__]
it's like friends with me so yeah no no
no he's nice and they're like he likes
school shootings and he's like I
guarantee you they're so literal in
Miami I guarantee you we like school
shooting he's like he literally said
he's happy when schools get shot goes
yeah he's a dick anyway what are you
guys doing uh
yeah well that's part of being friends
with you oh yeah tell me oh yeah defend
and then and then be like all right I'm
not gonna turn you right right oh yeah I
don't do that with someone says Mark's a
dick to me I'm like you're already such
a piece of [__] what specifically did he
do I love that he literally said that's
a big one literally literally said he
likes almost literal and then if you go
here's the playback they go ah whatever
like no whatever they're wrong thank you
I have to say I like that this is not in
the martini or the up glass because
people they do they do that I'm not a
big Martini so you want to be the yeah
the drink's already pink do I want to
look like I'm drinking a cosmo yeah this
is a whiskey drink yeah it's a whiskey
drink why do you put sometimes there's a
lemon peel and sometimes in orange peels
just it depends on how the oil will like
sort of accentuate the flavors of it
gay
that's a very good paper plan
oh that's nice that's nice try that
ready
[Music]
thank you
tastes like oral herpes
oh I already have it so I'm good is that
got grapefruit in it what is that no
it's a fresh lemon some of the bodega
cats straight Rye a little bit of fresh
lemon and amarno Nino quintessentia oh
wow is nice in the stomach you don't
feel you don't I should say I have a
gooey stomach I arrived here with
diarrhea as usual yeah it's a problem
it's a real problem it's like every day
is a Jew my body's rebelling against my
lifestyle well you're living like a guy
I talk about this my special Jew it's
available now but like uh we're in red
and we're falling apart we're actually
dying all the time I remember David tell
once said to me in a car I was so
hungover and he goes let me tell you
something Jews can't drink
that's true we can he's got we want it
we want to hang yeah somebody Irish
don't come you don't hear irish guys
complain about their stomach that's true
not at all I don't they're falling apart
too they're no they're no all they eat
is potatoes they get carbs and soak it
up we don't do that that's true that's
true polished is not a great booze
two questions for you guys yeah one can
we have a night this time I'm off from
June pretty much June 1st when I'm done
in Athens I'm gonna hang out for a bit
till end of October can we have a night
where we finish an entire Bodega cat uh
Rye over of a rock somewhere in the city
we can have a morning who cares yeah we
we did one of these on Rogan did we not
finish one of these we finished a whole
box I believe we did yeah I mean I would
love to have someone do a montage of
Mark Norman trying to push Bodega cat
and Rogan ignoring it
I've done that yeah yeah that's enough
of that you know what don't forget that
the bodega cap bottle is still falling
off the shelf it's legal in a lot of
cities right now you got that right and
it's 11 quickly and it's and I'll say
right here it's a damn good [__]
whiskey hell yeah
[Music]
so here's my other questions where's the
other guy where's Bear Jew
he's like I'll come back if I have to so
well you're not back then we're not
saving a spot for you no he's gonna he
might be gone four months five months no
he's talking a year plus first of all I
love that for him not great for the Pod
he's pulling an army basically Gary
veter does this all the time he's always
like I might not be able to do this gig
I'm like well then you might get
replaced with Anthony DeVito who drinks
good point you don't want to be the
sober guy who gets replaced with a
drinker the speeder trying to get you to
smoke weed no he stopped he doesn't he's
just kind of sober now he works out he's
so I mean he hangs he's got problems
like he's up at 10 A.M gambling
fatherhood has really done him bad the
one fatherhood is really done I know
it's boring yeah it's boring he's tuned
into that dude I don't know he gambles
oh he's got some Dark Souls when we went
to uh the March Madness weekend oh
you're right
[Laughter]
he was sitting on a phone book to
Seattle Storm all day he brought him he
bet on the Britney Griner release date
oh you know what I gotta do we do toes
sometimes on this I gotta do a toast
because I was with veter at the airport
where like you know we just It's a Grind
dog to grind dog no to a toast to uh
just people who give you the laugh in
public uh so veto and I are in line at
Quiznos and I say hey do you want to
water your little [__] and this black
one in front of us starts laughing
hysterically and I was like a toast to
that person I like that [__] too I like
when you're inappropriate in public and
someone just like joined and they like
that these guys are fun because we've
all had the opposite where they go oh
how dare you or whatever you're like
[__] you we're at the airport we're
living there's no way to talk to your
friend shut up yeah
give me a raspberry
don't make me show you my pen pants
I do declare about it he's like I'm
gonna hit you with a book knock some
sense into you
yeah old pimps have the best lines
hahaha
um so you want to be a full-time guy
here do you work uh yeah I work at a
little place in Gramercy it's called
Giorgio's giorgios sounds classy um no
not really it's kind of right by the uh
Gramercy Tavern plug yeah there you go
go to Georgios see old Shaney
what I've been known to do a little
little flowers
wow
this guy's impressing me yeah I agree
who else have you seen we had two two
last week two last week we have two more
this week after this
let's throw this out there yeah one one
episode over the summer me and DeRosa
guests bartend like we could die
that might be when dorosa dies yeah
it won't be long his doctor told me to
stop drinking he goes I want a second
opinion and his second doctor was like I
think you're ugly too
[Music]
is he opened a health shop oh wait he
owns a bar
literally a sandwich shop bar yeah
literally the most unhealthy [__] and
he's like it's the two places I go on
the way home from the stand
and these sandwiches are no picnic oh my
God no doctors like you know you need
more corned beef and whiskey yeah
that's a country song
The Rosa truly makes me laugh like
harder is one of the greatest guys one
of the funniest dudes yeah Joey roses I
didn't want to say it you will be missed
Joe yeah we love you rip
[Laughter]
so we're going to the Super Bowl and
Chrysler goes we got Shane we got Norman
we need one more guy so we all threw out
a bunch of names and then we looked up
most everybody was on the road yeah and
I said I know who won't be on the on the
road DeRosa so he's coming but he
doesn't even like sports
he was like uh just some light [__] uh
you know your 49ers didn't do well and
they weren't Sportsmen and Soder [__]
lost it on him he's like [__] you wow
you're a [__] [__] you're a girl you
don't watch sports wow and the girls are
like dug in a little more and then he's
like dude so I'm just getting mad I'm
like I know and it's over something
ridiculous so you should double down
he has no right to be mad at you so like
go harder you know he should have made
fun of some nerd [__] that DeRosa likes
he should have been like Star Wars was
overrated horror horror is not a good
genre yeah that's the only thing about
the rosie Star Wars yeah Doris is always
like like Star Wars the one the worst
ones yeah really well he's like he's
like a whiskey drinking Coke head guy
fun guy bar owner but I woke up at his
house once after a bender and I was like
where am I and it's just Nintendo video
games Star Trek poster comic books
yeah he has the house of someone who has
not gotten laid in a while yes
[Music]
oh that'll be good Joe but Joe will be
good at Super Bowl drink no one played
Mario 64 like Joe
[Laughter]
I can't ski dude are you kidding me I'm
a City hack I can't drive you think I
can ski you can't drive no you can't
even ride a bike
I'm worthless I have no balance you
don't even City bikes are a city thing
I've done it I I get wipe out at least
twice really yeah I'm not good well
people are reckless in the city patreon
they're I love it doesn't look like a
zoo but it comes out people are Reckless
well they they really go full speed they
try to cut you off
on a bicycle
ah this is adorable I'm not good are you
a good skier I'm pretty pretty good yeah
he's pretty good I'm not as good as
O'Neill he's the best one of the comics
I know but but um no you're pretty
[__] good and I got jumps down this
time and you got balls like you will go
hard he broke his wrist last time uh
trying to beat Bert no I was racing
O'Neill oh O'Neil this is a great sales
pitch by the way the good skiers
breaking bones yeah you're trying to
talk me into this well he's also a 78.
yeah exactly dude they're already
they're already brittle we need it can I
make a dealer's Choice uh drink for just
make one yeah what's yours because I
want to weigh so much with alcohol but
just make one we'll uh I brought a
couple stuff to make us yeah another
place my Judaism came out uh I don't
waste anything uh but yeah make a
dealer's choice and we'll we'll take a
sip and because we got we got other
bartenders we gotta
yeah yeah he's number one oh God no no
all right yeah [__] three per
whoa you don't have to finish them all
true we do have to kill them I got shows
yes I do yeah I had couples therapy
you have couples therapy after this yeah
no you don't yeah no I got bonfire first
I'll sober up a little you wear that hat
to couples therapy I think you're gonna
lose the boss
you were a legion of skank sweatshirt
is Lewis your therapist
[Laughter]
he just doesn't listen to me shut up
[__]
March 5th I'll be in Salt Lake City with
Mark Norman yeah
and Ryan O'Neal we're in Azizi Sean
Patton [__] All-Star show second show
just that a first shows yeah for sure
one of my favorite clubs talk about
sleep apnea watch out give him busy
Wednesday Thursday you're doing sold out
yeah six shows sold out Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Yeah Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday that's the new jail
which is well you're gonna sell it
regardless here's what happened I did it
to try to get into the NBA All-Star
weekend because they used to do a
celebrity game and there were people who
were pretty low level in that game so I
was like I can get in you thought you
got a chance Adam Ray did it I have a
chance oh Adam raided it yeah you're
bigger than him
this is my friend's talking me down here
I have a chance you're bigger than him
you do so so and Hassan Minaj Did It
Like years ago when he was like this is
different that's an ethnic pull don't
don't make you don't bring that [__] to
our podcast don't bring your [__]
[__] [__] here they're not like Indians
in basketball shut up do you know what
that is I need players but there were
people that I feel like I could get my
agents were confident but I don't think
they're doing a celebrity game now
what do you mean I don't think I think
they pulled that and they might Kevin
Hart ruined it no he's [__] good dude
he is good he's a good basketball player
and he's got a good tequila so if Kevin
Hart wants to come on here and promote
it wait oh yeah you gotta get in wait
they're not doing the All-Star I'm
pretty bummed about it who else is in
Sam's now I'm spending like foreign
basketball league should we like took
her as like a she was like hey she plays
so we took her as a sub once because
people go on the road
she's awful really yeah it's like you
built that up like she was good yeah
she's just like not good and everyone's
like oh everybody let her play because
she's like they like her but she's fun
she's a woman yeah but there's dudes in
the game
uh yeah she knows how to act like she
plays who else plays like she was like
the Gary Shandling game yeah who else
could play nobody's bigger than you yeah
who's who's a comic or or Rafi bastos he
used to play professionally oh he's
always trying to play with me but my my
neck is finally good enough to play
again okay but he's not a celebrity in
America
comics who's trying to get in no one's
trying to get it so what happened was uh
I didn't get in and now a Hilton Garden
Inn or whatever the hell I'm we should
believe where I'm staying but a [__]
hotel is like 400 something a night and
I'm bringing meat or something like this
is hilarious yeah you're losing money
now you know what the hell is it what is
it it's called Uh the witching hour the
witching hour oh Bieber's gonna play for
sure Bieber's gonna play okay he gets a
spot yeah okay I'm not saying I'm
[__] Bieber Right exciting you're not
starting but I'll make it I'll make it
fun I'll do some Antics who's that
awesome
this smells good though what is in the
witching hour so it's a tequila based
cocktail and I brought uh one of my
favorite liqueurs called Strega it's uh
kind of like a tomorrow it's a digestive
even though it's so light it's a saffron
on the core from Italy so a little bit
of fresh lemon thanks for bringing your
own [__] yeah
Shane
Shane O'Brien that is [__] excellent
that is a great drink hey cheers
because straight is the time for which
it's from a city called benevento or
kind of the home Gathering Place for
witches back in the day I don't know
so based off this wow that's good okay
very good there that's Colorado that's
and it and it goes down it's like
limoncello smells like it does smell
like jello
very nice oh yeah all right so you are
going to to Utah oh you're playing but
you're not doing the All-Star Game No
but it's all right are they not doing
this celebrity challenge I don't know
but I'm I'm a little who is the lowest
level celebrity that's played
I don't know this is a mean game to play
no no you could get in well it's like
Nate saying he wants to play in the
[__] program it's like who else is
there Nate yeah I know but how many more
years do I have of this honestly my
body's falling apart and I've been
training I want you to play I've been
training my jump shots back I put every
day on the road I bought my entire tour
basketball sneakers so they'd feel
guilty if they wouldn't play with them
every day so we were we were pooping
every day at the rec center and we're
playing full court with some some kids
who could hoop and look you want a
feeder I made veter play you found a
size five shoe
we got him the honestes everyone's
wearing the honest sneakers oh nice I
want it to be camaraderie yeah yeah you
know that's nice it was fun hey I'm
sorry I just got to break in here real
quick I I heard that kid say Hey Dad I
thought that was a joke that that uh uh
salacus actually has bread well you
think you think we just brought in a
random kid I don't know it was Peter's
kid no he looks just like him
[Laughter]
this episode
um I think you can get in but they don't
do it
I I don't know we didn't go I feel like
we're talking about this way too long
okay it's just not that interesting but
I mean you know uh we'll see I think you
got a shot I think you should go in
there and say hello so who's on the list
let us let us figure out who the yeah
look it up who played last uh NBA
All-Star celebrities we also do have to
get another bartender oh yeah Shane by
the way very impressive man like your
apron or like your style it looks like
corner of Brian that'll Play Good Flair
on the apron a couple of pins and
buttons great arms hey
hey folks this show is brought to you by
better help getting to know yourself can
be a lifelong process especially because
we're always growing always changing I'm
going right now I'm hard yeah therapy is
all about deepening your self-awareness
because sometimes we don't know what we
want or why we react the way we do until
we talk through it better help connect
you with a licensed therapist who can
guide you on that journey of
self-discovery we both do therapy you
got me in with the Big Al I'm hooked I
love them changed my life helps it's
good for you clear out the garbage if
you're thinking a therapy get better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com drunk today to get
10 off your first month that's better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash drunk get on it the
best way to prioritize you and your
health is to keep yourself hydrated with
liquid IV my favorite flavor is I like
watermelon Mark what do you like I like
pina colada use it first thing in the
morning before a workout when you feel
run down after you uh peed your pants at
a party the night before I use it
hungover uh it's free from gluten dairy
soy liquid IV contains three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks liquid Ivy uses cellular
transport technology designed to enhance
rapid absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream grab
your liquid IV in bulk nationwide at
Costco or you can get 20 off when you go
to liquid iv.com and use code drunk at
checkout that's 20 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code drunk at liquid
iv.com yeehaw
it's this plate time get your own
artwork printed on a metal poster that
only takes 20 seconds to install just
pop that magnetic sticker on the wall
and hang that poster no holes in your
wall and change it in seconds they have
officially licensed design from Fight
Club alien South Park and more if you
can think of it they can print it on a
metal poster
click the link in our description to see
some of our favorites and get get your
ready to hang piece of art that's 27 if
you buy one or save 27 if you buy one or
two and get 34 off when you buy three or
more discounts will automatically be
applied to your cart when you click the
link or use code drunk when you visit
display.com that's display.com code
drunk or click the link below of the
show notes
keep going
I do have to take a pee break my
bladder's [__] remember those uh
celebrity games you used to watch uh the
baseball the pro baseball celebrity
those were so fun
and uh Jimmy Kimmel or whoever was he
said it was the best day of his life
really he played in the celebrity
baseball he's not at a stadium did you
pull up the Chris
Christie's embarrassing
car lock I mean Brittany no there's some
Heavy Hitters Machine Gun Kelly's are
real
all right Alex two sets of Peloton
instructor what the [__] what I know but
some look some of those cuevos ahead
wait Anderson Varejao he can't play in
the All-Star in the celebrity no it's
fun to have some retired Pros in there
it makes the game fun that's true they
know what they're doing okay the other
team Olympic high jump Champion Krista
Jackson I'm better than Tiffany had if
she's bigger but I'm better Alex Jones
what are we doing here Alex Jones is a
mean crossover he crossed over to the
dark side all right all right all right
dude we gotta get we gotta get Muriel
into this yeah
guys start tweeting the NBA yeah
yeah they've been doing it already oh
okay there's no hope ask them if they're
cowards Santa's afraid that Sam real is
going to cross over one of their stars
and embarrass them or ruin all I want is
one clip of crossing over like a former
NBA get around so much just one like
just one drop step let's give me one
yeah all they have to do is give you a
bad potato salad the day before and
you're like I can't play all right I got
diarrhea no that'll be my Jordan Flu
Game Dude
on the court
we talked about the Vic yet no okay I'm
just I've been zooming all day I had six
Zoom meetings today with directors and
all these people who want to do it and
it's a [__] nightmare it's a
nightmare let me just go in bang it out
and yeah get get off my ass yeah you
know what you're doing yeah
I know this meeting suck well so how do
you want to do the sound I don't know I
don't know anything about sound for me I
want to do it well you're asking a guy
who doesn't even know the terms exactly
they're like we're gonna shoot with the
camera 6j red flare I'm like I don't
know anything about camera I've learned
how to tell these people like hey I
don't know these terms at all uh here's
a couple things I like can you make it
look like that one yeah and I did a
thing where I said don't give me any
gifts because like the agency and all
them they give you get which is nice
yeah but you have to pretend and go oh
well that's really great I don't want to
do that during that time give it to me
after yeah how about this how about this
oh girl bartender I know we're breaking
barriers
[Applause]
for a pH
Freaky Friday all right I had nothing
there both you digging
thank you Stephie
it's called Macau and Tribeca
like the like the the gambling Island
yeah yeah okay yeah
is it themed on that yes oh it's cool
oh
that's something a cool bar Macau is the
biggest gambling place in America or in
the world
all right well you're Hong Kong right
where are you from
Harlem hey you're not black
what the hell's going on it's all
different now there we go
oh yeah that's where Yeshiva is
um that's right yeah well you know I
went there for a year cheap real estate
um I played there once and bombed
horribly Shiva University yeah I died
too dirty too dirty and I I high-fived a
woman and they caught they pulled the
fire alarm it's like you died and went
to heaven what did I miss I'm sorry
Yeshiva years ago and bomb my tits off
damn but uh they just weren't happy
every woman was dressed like full neck
down you know every guy was in the curls
and the yamaka and I made a couple of
cracks about it I think they thought I
was Jewish and once it came out that I
wasn't they were like all right let's
get rid of this guy do you have
appropriated our culture a bit a little
bit I was legit do you know when you
were upset about like a roast joke or
something where you know you shouldn't
be but you are sure and like looking
back like I shouldn't have been sure
when you it bothered me when you won at
the creaky Awards best Jew I wasn't my I
know but I was like UPS I was in the
background it was new to New York and I
was like I might actually win this and I
was like he's not even doing I know I
shouldn't be upset about a fake award
show [__] Milli Vanilli over here
he's taking our [__] he's taking her
religion yep and look neither of us you
at least grew up very religious I was
you know I'm cultural though we're both
very culturally Jewish there's no
question true the Hat says it all
events I've heard that is hilariously
one that I forgot that I mean that was a
joke but still I get why I bugged you a
little really I was like all right
things we've called you I've called you
the k word and you're fine with that but
this fake award show yep I'm not proud
of it but I'm mad all right we'll take
it up with Rebecca oh I hit her
a lot of domestic violence talk this
week oh yeah you might get demonetized
again Steffy you're next
what do you got for us
um so what are we doing wait do we do
the same drinks with her yeah we see we
do we do a paper plane in Manhattan and
then a dealer's Choice and then a
dealer's Choice okay and I like the
bartender I like to keep my old one for
like a year and change I like it come on
up with it this podcast has been on
barely two years yeah so around the same
Miranda thing all right love it
um so what do I do first let's start
with the Manhattan please let's do it
and then oh [__] okay ice is here so
Steffy excluding the characters in the
room who's your favorite stand-up comic
okay I just watched Louis CK Specialists
number one it's insane I don't
understand how the man's brain works you
don't mind the balding
and it also sounds like she's forgiven
which is good yes yes great quality in a
woman she's not jerking us around
all right Steph all right so what do you
got so Manhattans Manhattan yeah that's
very uh New York well I would use the
bodega cat whiskey I think that's better
whiskey than the makers no this is Grand
Marnier oh okay in a Manhattan yeah wow
let her work I've never heard of it let
me know yeah let me know what you think
I am bars Blanding right now God damn
backseat bartender
is that the bars playing the theme song
when he gets an on-time sound cue it has
caused a celebration right very rare
yeah yeah
I was like what is this about what
happened
earlier today
I keep drinking this old paper plane so
good so it's gonna be tough to top there
Steph also when it gets a little watery
it's less Tangy I do I do like a little
water water down there yeah sometimes it
helps I don't like a sweet drink but I
do the paper plane is it's funny I was
texting Tom Papa who's like a cocktail
snob and uh
he's he's always just talking it was
Papa John
a lot of n words yeah but Tom Papa uh is
like trashing the paper plan we when we
get him back on here we have to have him
have one oh that sounds disgusting
he's like he didn't like it no he's
saying he hadn't even tried it yeah
he's texting me black
that's appropriating yeah no he spells
with a K okay okay
it smells like a [__]
all right no but I wanna yeah I want him
to try one but yeah he's like a martini
guy he hated the martinis on here oh
really they were greasy we were using
those they were a little greasy what's
your standard drink that you have on
every podcast episode
is an exaggeration it's a lot no it's
actually matters we've had it two or
three times Frederick I've never heard
of no more than two or three times oh
well nerd out there go through the
records
I like a cocktail that a whiskey based
cocktail that isn't played out like I
love it it's not played out for sure
it's kind of an underrated whiskey
cocktail yeah look I love old Fashions I
love Manhattans But like everyone drinks
those so it's fun to have a different
one in the mix an old pal is another one
we know old pal is a classic
I think I believe it's just dry vermouth
look it up it's drivermooth whiskey and
yeah
vermouth is a good mixer there it is
what's the ingredients one ounce whiskey
one ounce Campari one ounce dry vermouth
and the garnish is a lemon twist that's
a weird mix right there yeah but simple
it's simple I mean yeah it's so it's
whiskey and vermouth and that's it uh
something else uh Campari uh Campari
it's like a Negroni no but it doesn't
sleep okay those bird uh morning drinks
with something with Campari it was a
Campari Spritz at your back Spritz no
but it's a compartment that's right nice
you made him nice in the morning yeah
damn bird is clutch with a bird with the
alcoholism
hungover like tired and it's like coffee
like I got a better thing for you guys
because we did these boys in here yeah
we planned all these weird events in the
morning and you had we were hung over
the night before you get two hours of
sleep so you needed that kick yeah bird
is sending me we were both on tour buses
and were sending each other videos of
our tour buses because his is like a
double deck I'm going to a fight record
about tour buses but then also he's like
you know he's like this is my room where
I sleep I'm like I'm in a bunk with
everyone else dude I'm doing the bunk
yeah I sleep better in the bunk yeah the
bunk is better the bunk is good then a
bed yeah because you're in the back and
it's like bouncy and [__] it's like
you're by the end box oh right because
that's where it bounces The Backs yeah
yeah but then you get a bunk you kind of
it's like a I was gonna say a coffin
it's kind of nice little known let alone
facts about Bert's tour bus I saw it in
Madison he was parked and I was like
knocked on the door it's like 11 A.M
whatever nothing and then I tried the
door it was open walked in saw
somebody's like uh
and then I walked to the back woke bird
up
so little on tip is if you see burst
tour bus it is unlocked
that's true go say hi I can vouch yeah
well I'm taking it let's wait for Ari to
get a sip of this one yeah yeah
do you have a third one I do have a
third one but I don't have any glasses
okay one thing I'll say about bird is he
we did the fully loaded and he went to
bed last we'd all stay up watching
movies and getting drunk and high and
all this [__] he would stay up last you
know show us his dick whatever then he'd
be up early shirtless doing a slip and
slide he's like the Michael Jordan of
drinking he's making when he hears like
a mantle Mickey Mantle of drinking but
when you hear Michael Jordan stories
they're like you play 18 holes of golf
yeah he'd go to practice lost fifty
thousand dollars on one hand yeah and he
was still first there at 40. yeah he is
that guy
and you know everybody goes and once he
stops he's gonna die but he stops no he
stops and he's fine I know yeah yeah
I've stopped doubting him I doubted him
too many times yeah are you going in are
you doing it oh [__] I'm gonna wait no
we're waiting for me all right there we
go
this is interesting so it's in so it's
in the glass I like but without a cube
I'm curious to see how this plays out
and they've all been up so far good
smell it reminds me of something oh that
smells good does it remind me of that is
a unique taste
Grand marinades and orange liqueur or no
well I guess it's that so this is kind
of your own spin on the Manhattan yeah
that's different that's different I'm
not big on sweet vermouth so whenever I
make drinks with it I try to find ways
to put it yeah offset it make it like
nicer interesting and she's from
Manhattan it's I think it's a great
cocktail I don't think it's a Manhattan
Heidi Klum in the house I would not say
it's Manhattan that's a totally
different I think it's very good though
I think it's called a harlem yeah
exactly yeah technically but this is on
103rd Street right here yeah yeah up on
103rd Street yeah it is good but I would
agree it's not a man but I really
genuinely like it yeah it's really I
like it too I would name that something
else this is how we make our cocktails
at my bar or Manhattan's at my bar like
that's our standard where's your bar in
uh in Tribeca it's called Macau Macau
it's like a Chinese theme yeah so maybe
that's why
um yeah actually maybe yeah because you
do everything wrong
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right well all right that was I'm
I'm it's gonna be hard not to drink all
this I know I know I got [__] to do
tonight same it's hard to shoot the show
in the afternoon
it really is I have people hitting this
up like can I come on next week I'm only
in town and I'm like is how much
diarrhea can I handle in one week yeah
you're drinking because it's not like we
don't drink off the podcast right it's
not that's not the only time you drink
no yeah Jay wants to get a bowling
league going for comedians but I'm like
where would you do it have to be Monday
or Tuesday yeah we're busy it doesn't
either be 5 p.m before spots or like 11
p.m after spots and then continue and
the problem is this is gonna sound
elitist yeah but as a new comic you can
do all that [__] but now we're on the
road we're doing it we're scheduled yeah
but that [__] never works I mean we I
feel like we always try to do it and it
never works but they used to have
Community I know but who's
wow yeah but you had more time you'd
have to post Clips you'd have to edit
caption podcasts all that [__] guys
never done any of those things
a lot of black guys right now yeah all
right you're on every [__] podcast
what are you talking about I don't
caption [__] I have a guy doing it yeah
right there you go we don't have to do
it we're crazy bowling
I don't even like bowling bowling's hard
it's hard I'm so bad at it that I can't
enjoy it but let's just be drunk and do
it let's be drunko bowling steal some
shoes but it's all gutter yeah sure all
right that's what our minds are anyway
yeah nicely done that's actually a good
name for a bowling alley your minds your
minds anything good or hey stay in your
lane
but uh okay I'm not a big easy but I can
enjoy I'm bad at ping pong and I enjoy
ping pong I love ping pong but I'm not
good I'm bad at pool I enjoy pool I
don't really like bowling you know what
it is bowling's a big to do the shoes
the waiting for them
a pool shot even Pros Miss no big deal
and you're not walking around here it's
all right there bowling you're moving
you're holding a heavy ball you're
throwing it it's loud there's other
people there maybe you are Jewish
okay I've been accepted
finally we'll try to do this instead of
this
but you know uh yeah I love watching
bowling like I love watching a great day
no not like really what but like
watching a guy who's great at it it's
kind of beautiful the way they put the
spin on it I mean dilutes yeah you know
what I've heard of him he was a [__]
he was a fan he was a he was ranked like
fifth in the in the world in Bowling one
yeah I won 32 Grand that year he's on
next week that is cool to be that good
at something I went to see it once I'm
in a meme oh that guy's
who do you think you are I love this
look at this look at that the way they
put the spins
I just think of Ernie McCracken
every time
it's so funny these guys get laid of
course they do they're good who Do You
Think You Are I Am the motion for error
is this what'd you bang this guy if he
absolutely not really can you find the
meme I'm in Bully meme
yeah I was that I was watching Tommy
delutes at a [__] bowling event and
somebody put up the sign behind me
nothing to do with me they just played
there you are there it is oh look at
look at the sign what a great sign
with hair and glasses whoa look at that
sign in the back defense I gotta say you
look way better now it's bowling yeah
you do so you really do this is like in
cell Ari yeah a little more rap this is
crazy definitely much for sure you can
see the Yeshiva Universe you've aged
very well yeah thanks you're a good
handsome guy
yeah what a hat helps
what uh do you have any pet peeves
what's that just in life
like slow Walkers
um classic it's a big one here uh what
else
um people who like sing or hum loudly
like when doing anything good one
um it's not bad
um you know what stuff is the loudy
honor oh my God I get it we're all bored
you're on my show I guess
could we do a round of Paper Planes yeah
are we ready yeah I mean yeah we can't
finish all of these you know what maybe
just do one maybe just do one because
that's a good call
yeah yeah that's not about a call
we can give the rest of them
to the homeless yeah dude you ever have
like a nice drink just hand the magic
did you leave a club and you're like hey
do you want some Scotch yes they're like
yes of course kidding me I drank
everything off the bar when I was coming
up that's a good charity drinks your
hobos yeah Mark Norman literally owned
his own apartment and he was still
eating chicken wings off plates going
towards the kitchen there's something
about it when it's not yours it's more
fun it's like a guy's wife yeah it's
true forbidden you're a food cook yes
yes food cook yeah somebody get that
domain name no I know what you mean
though it's something exciting like uh
uh there's not something we could do
something with this booze for hobos oh
yeah yeah this is a charity because dude
dude that's a that's a weird book
exclusive it's great to book big name ax
on a show like this because no one ever
asked we're just like it's a charity gig
I'm like oh cool oh we get the homeless
intoxicated dude you get a bartender
Steffy anybody yeah we go down there
with a little makeshift like travel and
bar and we make an actual drink for all
the [__] heroin acts of Tompkins or
the for the Washington Square Park
[__] drug addict I love it dude it's
dicey now though they would love it they
legalized drugs in Portland why not we
they we make free booze so cool they're
gonna get it anyway what do you think of
this one what's better the boulevardier
paper plane you got hobos going well
this one's full body you did all that
[__] that would be hilarious 100
sideways but everyone's homeless yes all
right because look I've had some hobos
that turned down my food I go hey I got
some Indian food you want just take out
they go oh what am I a piece of [__] we
do have to donate a shitload of money if
we do this to the homeless Charities you
can't just do this [__] you give them
the Boost
if we get lit up we can't just be
getting people drunk without doing the
other [__] all right all right all right
guys sandwiches
oh that's a sponsor Joey roses
all right this is big
Joe's drunk eating all the sandwiches
next to them
I love that sale yeah that sound is the
opposite of peeve because you know
something good is coming that has a good
sound unless you're an open mic comic
and you're like okay shut up can you
wait
sat in the blender yeah
there it is
on Fifth Avenue he's getting it for the
hobo now there's something about that's
you're right when you're on stage and
you hear it oh yeah we're a vehicle to
move alcohol and nothing else that's it
and you hear the blender like all right
I know what everyone's drinking it
always hits you right when you feel like
an artist for a second yes you're like
I'm getting pretty good at this
and you're like I'm a [__] piece of
[__] I gotta ask Steph do you hate ice
what's going on here paper planes and
well Manhattans typically you asked and
that was my mistake I didn't ask you did
you want it on the rocks are up the
paper planes planes are usually up it
should be in a coop but you're right you
should be in one of these yeah she did
say when she served it she goes
technically it should be one of these
but these degenerates don't have enough
glasses for me you got that right
sending calls to the studio that's why
we need more glasses Restoration
Hardware hit us up uh should we try it
yeah you start it smells great Paper
Planes is just great we've I feel like
we really are responsible for the rise
100 popularity in homeless we did what
Pulp Fiction did for John Travolta oh
that's good that's a better paper plane
than the other one wow all right
your stomach
that is a that is mind-boggling maybe
the best paper plane we've ever seen on
this podcast I'm saying it's good Trump
says it beard you is going to kill
himself with a with a [__] in
Thailand or wherever he is guess what I
hate ice too now I guess so so does the
Border Great that's really good so do
the immigrants kick it back thank you it
was that was that's maybe I think it's
the best paper very nice can we go
dealer's choice now yeah so uh it's a
good name for a drink yeah it's [__]
with sidecars no no forget what we [__]
with I love a sidecar yeah that's what I
like make few Jewelers I believe it's
the Godfrey episode we did sidecars is
that correct
yeah
yeah keep that away from me so why is
that is a good drink why is sidecar your
specialty it's I mean not my specialty
it's just kind of what I've been
enjoying drinking lately
um I just I couldn't come up with a
specialty I don't really have one I'll
just make whatever people want but I've
been really liking these can I tell you
how to drink the inventor The Comedy
Store I got sidetracked with the last
guy so they had about you know how they
had like the liquor uh whatever delivery
guys will be like hey we have one free
bottle of this just because you guys
might want it you know so they had a
bottle of uh cherry vodka
yeah
anyway so we saw it there we're like
let's make a drink cherry vodka with
Sprite and grenadine so it's pretty much
a Shirley Temple but with like vodka
yeah what did Shirley Temple have in it
vodka right well the Dirty Shirley uh
Shirley Temple's just grenadine ends oh
right right oh [__] I gave him a Dirty
Shirley so is it Dirty Shirley but since
we called it with that we decided to
call it since it's a grown-up Shirley
Temple uh uh Temple of Doom I like that
yeah and we it was good I tried to make
him do it at the stand he goes I will
not do that tastes even better with an
Asian kid
All-Star Game come on
round worst Indiana Jones movie but
still easily the worst dude is that this
one
but as a kid I love that [__] yeah oh
yeah that was huge man Harrison Ford
[__] ruled Harrison Ford ruled and he
didn't even make it so it was like 35.
he was like a carpenter strawberries he
was older no but he was in the he was in
movies so he wasn't like conversation
and [__] young and it was an American
Graffiti but he was a hot Carpenter in
La just like banging all these
Housewives he was a [__] hot dude
yeah like Jesus if Google [__] was here
we could uh pull up some photos of him
but where the [__] did he go he's
talking to Child Protective Services
outside yeah
he's in school he's in tutoring right
now
is that we had him take one sip is that
whiskey
fun fact Harrison Ford was just reading
the scripts he was a script reader and
they hired him wow because he was so
charming and fun
oh yeah that's a dream as a script
reader like they're gonna see my talent
yes it only happened one time ever pull
up Harrison Ford is a carpenter hot
young hot young beefcake
yeah
I think there's one of him shirtless
floating around somewhere my mom and he
hooked up with Carrie Fisher too oh
really did he ever I mean they really
[__] that was how Hollywood worked
back then if you were like if you were
like leading there is a carpenter wow
he's like a hip ripped yeah but you
realize how much better people's bodies
are now
both of us maybe yeah but for Leading
Men
oh right you got to be caught the fact
that we're even in the conversation
right now is disgusting
yeah you had to go on roids now back
then everyone's on roids drinking he's
not even like no he does look good there
and it's before they knew anything he
was eating white bread and you know yeah
exactly eats her steak it's good for you
yeah drinking beers all day yeah not
like us we're really healthy
smoke weed on every shoot he's like I'm
gonna be [__] ripped and that he made
a decision like 20 years ago yeah
there's a clip I wonder if you could
find it it's like him and Josh Hartnett
an award show and I think he's like
[__] wrecked really Jason Ford he's
he's either high as [__] or drunk as
[__] something's off but yeah I wonder
if it exists there's also a club of him
at Comic-Con he went one year for the
paycheck and they're like Han Solo he's
like you guys got to grow up here
oh this is it yours is this it oh
Stiffler hold on man oh here it is
I think he's wrecked let's get this
going
yeah Lucas
[Music]
okay don't worry about it you never
understood what I'm doing just keep
reading
[Music]
for the talent they consistently bring
to the screen snakes
yeah he's doing all his famous lines
[Laughter]
it's a gag and he's drunk yeah
I'm doing the MTV Awards I don't give a
[__] yeah
he's being fun
no this is planned
[Music]
women we're playing along yeah
good for him he doesn't want to be there
get off my plane is one of the all-time
dumbest greatest lines
Air Force One but the Russian the
Russian terrorists and he's literally
the this back when being patriotic was
cool yeah right when you like you root
for the president and he's literally the
president is the action star can you
picture Biden or Trump as a dude beating
up terrorists
literally through this last scene this
is it he's this is Iconic
I think that's Gary Oldman
[Music]
no hold it for here that's perfect
oh everybody in the theater was going oh
no let it play later
get off my music yeah oh yeah what a
country
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh he's hanging what's he hanging from
he broke his neck first and threw him
out in a parachute oh first he threw he
broke his neck yeah George Bush Senior
was a real uh hero
in hindsight history will be kind to
that guy
whenever you start painting shit's gun
horribly yeah that's true Hitler Jim
Carrey yeah no I think Hitler he was
pre-painted oh yeah yeah yeah it voted
not well but Jim Carrey is a good
example yeah he started painting
Stephanie's got a new drink yeah that's
W or no the original uh George Bush
being rescued this one I'm loving
steffy's drinks right now the
presentation see that's the woman's
touch yeah yeah very nice you left the
nail in here
it's a rusty nail it's been a while
since I've had a woman's touch
[Laughter]
Stephanie Stephie Stephie Stephanie I
[__] up
take it again drunky okay take it again
start over and go she forgave Louie she
can forgive me
phenomenal get off my play
get off my paper plane
nice this is a paper plan no this is
excellent
if sidecar's always tasted like that I
drink them more often oh that's
interesting I like it what a player
Manhattan one more time
what's the proper way to like lick up a
salt or Sugar Ribs you you go like that
usually do like I'll take a sip and then
take a look Chaser yeah same with like a
margarita yeah
that's my way though I don't know the
official way
that's I think if you come back we don't
call this a Manhattan we call it a
Midtown West because that's where we are
[Music]
realtor talk I have something off with
this
oh Steffy
what do you think
it tastes like barf it's like papaya
there's something reminiscent of barf
could it be the glass
I thought he was gonna be mean I told
you Ari uh he likes to speak like a
Somali legitimately the other drinkers
in my life there's something in here
that I don't like it's not that it's
wrong it's not agreeing with you might
just not like sidecars
it's a lemon juice
um orange liqueur or Grand Marnier and
uh cognac maybe it's one of those let me
smell the green one yeah
yeah you don't like it I think it's a
good drink either I think it's good too
but it is it is it does pack a punch
it might be that
might be that it's something it reminds
me of something from childhood some
level of like I failed a class and I
smelled that at the same time
anyone molested and I was molested uh
yeah it might be related to the
molestation yeah dude yeah I keep trying
to bury that but it keeps popping its
head up you were diddling a sidecar no
oh this is worth it very nice
oh God kid her diddled he perked up
gotta be honest one of the that other
drink was one of the best drinks I've
ever had the paper the paper the paper
my paper plate yeah
[Laughter]
I think things you don't like now yeah
yeah exactly no that's fine that's part
of it it wasn't like it's rock it's just
like it's not my taste I think he killed
it I think it's definitely killed it for
sure very nice
all right would you like where New
York's headed do you feel like it's
different now it's definitely different
I'm ready to leave hello are you moving
where are you going um I am not sure yet
I was on the list I have a lot of
friends in Colorado who are trying to
get me out there I don't like the cold
um I like the Arizona sunsets but I feel
like there's not much to do January this
is incredible Denver sunsets are pretty
epic you don't like the cold so cold but
New York's not even that cold right now
I know Colorado would be way colder oh
yeah so [__] Colorado I don't know
um
to make any decisions now anyway so how
old are you okay 27. oh yeah all the
time in the world actually good call
Great town it's awesome
San Diego is underrated a lot of
military guys oh cakes oh yeah
guys with huge chests like us yeah yeah
Sam is it a burden to be this swole
well I think you killed us Stephie that
was a great job okay thank you really
good and we have one more bartender
right who that and who is that who did I
say they're gonna be them saints
Cameron is the third male or female
but it could be male cameras from uh
Ferris Bueller's Day Off but also
Cameron Diaz
Cameron Esposito Cameron Esposito's
serving us now I think it's Cameron Crow
oh yeah wow that does go both ways so do
I I'm all right
all right Stephy
great video great eyebrows thank you
legitimately it's not just that I prefer
the the
um paper plan that was one of the best
drinks I've ever had that was yeah I I
don't want to besmirch the name of
beerju but that's it is the best paper
plane we've had pretty damn good yeah I
appreciate it he'll die out there anyway
yeah all right godspeed and praise Allah
yeah all right one more one more so what
are you guys gonna do have a regular
I'm gonna have a regular guest I don't
know yeah yeah I'm impressed with both
of them yeah he's gone for months so we
need somebody to fill that time yeah you
need somebody yeah he might never come
back tarosa is a bartender the more I
think about it really worries me yeah
gerosa just pouring shot after I mean by
the way your bachelor party like the the
actual one that you guys were at we did
like a bachelor party episode and DeRosa
just keeps pouring shots it's crazy it
was no different than the real bachelor
party literally showed up with a bunch
of shirts that's true yeah but I was
sick for like eight days after that I
think I came in with a cold but I I
tried to fight through it because it was
the bachelor party episode yeah and
every time he did a shot I was like I'm
gonna be I was in Phoenix after every
set I collapsed on the couch violently
ill and the whole time Gary veteran was
just going we were supposed to go to
Pizzeria Bianco
we'll just be the same [__] we'll be out
in public and he goes you better take me
I threw a five-star restaurant tonight
[__] ah Gary He's like sharing the
Stone in Casino
where's my pink coat and what The
Roaster does is a bartender a lot of
bartenders have great ideas new
interesting interesting takes on drinks
or just do the old drinks quite well
Teresa does none of those but adds peer
pressure on a level that no bartender is
so true it's sickening peer pressure
come on he's oh he's always like come on
just do this shot I think I'm good come
on and then 20 minutes later he's
throwing up in a bush and I'm like oh
yeah why was I listening to you you're
right that's how he gets laid too hey
all right okay Cameron massage yes I try
you brought your own mixer no this was
given to me okay a travel light yeah we
uh yeah no DeRosa puking in the bush is
is the best is how the night ends
usually yep
he will be missed Cameron yes sir yes
you're the you're the third guy you know
the drill you gotta make a paper plane a
Manhattan and then your own special and
just make one of the paper planes and
one of them in hands and we'll each
other we're a little lit up we're a
little lit up and we have right now but
also uh
yes and also just make one of your
signature too so like it's it's those
two and then like uh what's your fave to
make or or are you guys you're gonna
love this whatever you want to make it
yeah and you're great and every Taylor
Sheridan show
he looks like somebody yeah you do you
do have rip Vibes for sure
you can look at your remake our house I
can't actually yes
whoa really yeah and then I bartend on
the side hell yeah bartending like got
me through college but now it's built
houses wow you were a puppet man yeah
same same tasks you just took yeah
and the flannel too real easy yeah right
here nah maybe a little Russian
what's your 23andMe like ethnic
background types it's 97 ashkenazic Jew
and three percent ashkenazic Jew
I'm I'm very high astronauts
we kind of have the same what is it
what's it legitimately easily related no
more than three generations back easy
you probably have something going on
yeah nice let's do it next time I come
in 23andMe contest similar build tall
comic sums up yeah a little hairier than
should be yes yeah nice map Matt with
the ice I have a hint of uh like Iranian
I have a hint of it I think that's the
eyebrows probably yeah I can see it yeah
but
is that Sephardic
is like uh
yeah yuck yeah got it oh my God that's
the uh that's the 20 what is uncut gems
do
the diamonds juice yes to eat the Opium
no I think the Ethiopians yeah that's
that's different they're cushy but like
yeah Sandler is an Ashkenazi Jew yeah
most got it I feel like a lot I feel
like Ashkenazi Jews mostly like Eastern
European type his real name is St Louis
huh San Luis no Adam sandlowitz is that
a bit no oh wow is it real Adam Sandler
wits not even Sandler San Luis well you
know uh Jon Stewart is Leibowitz
Leibowitz Trump used to get him on that
yeah yeah
it's good rules
okay I mean really thank God for iPads
it's funny when we were kids it was Game
boys they were like this big now it's
like this I had a comic book yeah yeah
books yeah
[Laughter]
are we doing Manhattan first oh this is
my first the specialty cacao all right I
figured you had the other ones
I like it I like it all right can we
know what it is this is a ward eight
award eight Ward eight yes sir what is
that this is uh your Bodega cat rye
whiskey orange flesh lemon a little bit
of maraschino cherry a dash of Bitters
and then I'm gonna have to garnish it
with a couple
whoa I've never heard of this drink a
ward eight I've never heard of it see
where I come from Massachusetts oh the
1898 election the governor that won
actually needed Ward 8 to win and after
he won the bars made
wow I love a history yeah Joe let's
drink this until seven years ago well we
have Wards in New Orleans but we call it
the eighth Ward or the Seventh Ward not
Ward eight with his wife it's called the
last word
all right let's see what this is made
real American whoa It's So pink
yeah just like my ex all right
we're at the point where we start
bombing
that's really the thank you sorry Start
us off man all right for the viewing
public it looks beautiful it does look
beautiful
is there a tip to like how thin to slice
these orange slices I like to do like an
eighth to 3 16 of an inch
dude I'm in the exact same way anything
more and it feels like you're eating
oranges and it's not a garnish
interesting it becomes a fruit salad but
sometimes it is fun to like when you're
drunk to be like I'm gonna I'm gonna eat
this orange yeah for sure yeah and I'll
eat the whole thing I'll eat the rind
and everything yeah
what do you think their nose smells good
I mean you could smell a pizza shop
[Laughter]
this guy's half gay
this was an orgy I'm the last dick in
come on
directly
back clean up
solid oh orange drops okay board eight
board
so what's the verdict
solid very good dry not too sweet which
I like too sweet orange juice I think it
helps out a little bit I like this
better
than what then a fresh orangey Orange
has so much sugar in it I think wow this
is interesting
tell me uh two ounces of rye whiskey
then a half ounce of fresh orange fresh
lime a tablespoon of maraschino cherry
juice two dashes of Bitters and then you
shake it up over rocks this is you would
think the maraschino cherry juice would
have made it super sweet just a little
bit yeah
there you know this is a really good
drink great drink I love it
Ward 8.00 yeah the last round the
sidecar was a classic that already did
not like this and the first guest
bartender Shane were both like that was
an original yeah the witching hour and
this is one we've never tried so it's
new to us I love the new ones so in the
original category we have to decide how
much weight to put on that but this is a
[__] that's a banger that's a banger
yeah okay it's a good drink that was
good too it's phenomenal also I would
order that at a bar would you yeah
and they'd know 100 ah maybe maybe
Advanced what kind of bar you're going
to do you know how to make a Godfather
no oh
what's your favorite drink sorry it's so
it's kind of but it's also like you go
into a bar like you make gamma like most
bars have never heard of it yeah it's
much better than the Godfather Three but
then
too like that first bartender you're
like interesting
damn that is so solid so that's a good
drink but what is your favorite Mitch
Hedberg joke
Jesus favorite Hedberg joke
the one I say the most is I used to be
an alcoholic I still am I used to do
drugs I still do but I used to too
that's a great joke brilliant joke you
know my favorite Hedberg joke is you
can't please all the people all the time
and last night all those people were at
my show yeah that's all do that live
really
whoa favorite Hedberg joke
uh uh some guys passing out flyers
they're pretty much saying here you
throw those out for me that's a great
joke classic great joke mark
uh hold on I'm on the spot here
escalators the only things that when
they break they still work they just
become stairs yeah how about the one
about the reservations
in France yeah there was someone's trunk
right now but no one seems to give a
[__] I got mine I'm against picketing
but I don't know how to show it
well that's a good one come on yeah
that's a banger Steven Wright I think is
the the ultimate one-liner I think it's
all they're almost like originated it
yeah well Henny Youngman made yeah he
originated but he had his own style yeah
there's nowhere dry like that yeah so I
had a friend Andrew
um
I forget he was in the um Hong Kong
comedy scene and those guys would go
around southeast Asia or Asia in general
and he went to the soul he went to Seoul
with a couple of comics they flew him
out there and they had never seen a
one-liner comic before and then they saw
him do that just like Steven Wright
style and they go dude you just changed
the game wow yeah but they just never
seen it changed again yeah and he had
the thing down where he looked weird and
he would go on stage to go feeling kind
of hyper so he knew his voice he knew
the [__] which made him oh dude I love I
went to a diner said eat breakfast
anytime so I ordered French toast during
the Renaissance come on
[__] incredible who is that Stephen
right wow I gotta get into him oh dude I
have a pony get listen to that album
yeah he tours all right all right get
him in here he's not great on butts you
started wait I started the last one all
right I'll start this one we'll move
what is that one the old-fashioned
Manhattan oh just the two Manhattan I
thought old-fashioned's fine all right
same same family I mean if they were
cousins they couldn't really [__] but
come to Louisiana
wait a minute you guys you made those
quick yeah man you're here you're on the
move I like that that's not a bad uh
details the smell of this [__] is
excellent nailed it smell matters
[Music]
um
it's a good old-fashioned
here here
that's good what is that one
that's good it's a good old-fashioned I
think I might just like Paper Planes
paper planes are good drinks that's a
damn good paper plane better than the
last one a little more kick than the
last one but this one has ice that one
didn't
[__] that's excellent it tastes weirdly
different yeah it does did you go heavy
on any ingredient here equal parts equal
parts
man we got some good bartenders that's
dry is it old-fashioned yeah that is dry
yeah I like my old-fashioned sweet I
like just like a I don't like them
sweeties make them stop burning so much
but not enough they're like oh this is
oh that goes down I want him to hurt me
like a woman
I don't I want him to deceive me or play
games yeah how do you declare this is
one of the finest old-fashioned Santa
makes a man's drink you make a man's
[__]
potatoes
now we got I got a decent bows from all
this yeah oh yeah good Buzz
that's nice I think I might just like
Paper Planes it's because that's
different than steffy's yeah
well they're both it's actually quite
good
very good kid you want to try it
come here
all right does he want Coke is It
surprising that Mark Ari and I are not
fathers
I've got some kids in heaven yeah yeah
would you know my name
that'd be a funny um scene in a movie
like the the courtroom the mom and the
dad is trying to keep the kid well he
brought him to a drinking podcast all
right that's it
can I come in drunk I'm like we're ready
to testify
I love the testified drunk he's in a
Hawaiian shirt for some reason I run I
run the place
I'm a Google [__] I don't even know
that it's a technical term he's in a
Hawaiian shirt carries a knife
on him oh my God yeah you were in
Hawaiian shirt and you rock a knife that
is hilarious that you're like you are a
good father yeah these I think are
stiffer protector you're protector
you're protector these are stiffer than
uh stiffy yeah these are those but I was
stiffer with Steffy
flip it solid word play stephie's not
gonna like it that's a samurai level
wordplay
interesting that Steffy is from New York
and is like I'm done with New York yeah
where are you from uh New York I was
born in the Hamptons are you looking for
a couple years and now I'm back out
there for now all right back out here
how do you like the city I love the city
what's what's your favorite part that
story yeah whoa I won't say Stephie I I
loved her she lost a couple points by
saying she was leaving New York well
yeah I was like how are you gonna be a
full time exactly not that everyone has
to stay here but it does it just makes
my heart sink a little bit when people
the whole New York is dead Vibe it hurts
me a little bit it's not New York is
dead but if you were I'm over here yeah
this is gonna this is a bad comment
because you were born here so is it at
some point you got to get out but maybe
I mean I'm talking to a guy who's like
has no intention of leaving him born
here I'm gonna I'm gonna go out like the
old man in Shawshank I leave for a
[__] day I go to Pennsylvania I'm
gonna hang myself it is a great City I
go for like a couple of days but like
too long I'm on the road every week
anyway so I kind of get my my break from
New York the reports of New York's
demise are greatly exaggerated I agree
it's an amazing City like whoa It's Not
Over late it's like oh oh so only every
place is open until 10. I go to Kansas
City what the [__] are you talking about
I know huh you can still nothing's open
everything closes oh yeah right right
well also it's really just like Monday
Like Mondays instead New York is exactly
like I'll get this open I was with Ryan
Hamilton last night and he was like
let's go to this restaurant let's go to
this restaurant and it was a Monday so
he was you know he was like ah these are
all closed I said yeah but if it was
Tuesday or Wednesday would be fine it's
a little bit farther back than it was
but it's still New York it'll be back
it'll be bad it's not what it was we
went to what's a fohawk yeah
closed it was closing like 10 30.'s
always open 24 hours it was back in the
day that's the [__] uh French diner
and the the awnings say 24 hours and I
got there like at 9 45 we're close 9 40.
veselka's midnight now and that was an
all-nighter too and that was like a
classic that was a classic all nighter
that hurt you got to get it back you're
known as an all-nighter you got to get
back you got that was two a.m and then
you'll get there too because then you'll
be the only spot that is open that late
and people they'll be like right [__]
they came back but nobody wants to work
uh summer will work uh nice shift has
got to be pretty rough yeah
that's tough
there's certain things so we're talking
to Liz about it as a waiter at the night
shift about the seller short shorts and
she goes we're not doing the brush
anymore because uh the cooks don't want
to go me and Mike Cannon were like
we'll do it let's make omelets yeah but
you're gonna you're gonna tank the
business why one guy's gonna go is this
jizz
you get what you get that's what we
decided you can order one Orion Cannon
meal and that's what you get you get
whatever we make sure
one out let's say three meals there will
be dosed also like just do like bagels
and locks just make it easy just make it
easy there you go let's have fun all
right okay have fun but have an option
where it's not fun no fun a no fun I
want to know fun I'd like to order one
no fun please are they really not doing
the brunch at the South yeah that meant
Hannah will do it see nobody wants to
work no who wants to work they were
pissed I didn't show up one day Esty was
like you're coming right and I was like
I got a thing I had a thing at the time
it was like two you know hungover
I was puking I saw Chappelle there once
and I was like the brunch at the brunch
he showed up for you know free bagels
and free bagels or was he still on from
the night before maybe I saw the show uh
chappellen Rock how was it I mean I mean
I didn't catch all of Chappelle because
I was exhausted we were we had been on
the road like five nights and we're in
St Louis and rock was in our uh did I
tell this story last week yeah okay
sorry but it's a cool story yeah after
well but all that I mean long story
short we got to watch a great [__]
show I mean Rock's new album
yeah he was great his kills he was uh he
had to stretch yeah he was the best one
at The Comedy Store for about a
five-year period like literally just any
employee who watches every night who's
the best one like Rick Ingram why does
he put something out he's about to tape
a special all right have you ever put
out a special he was a crowd work guy
for a long time and nobody was like I'm
gonna do that until you know the
industry's like can you figure it out
industry right right but but doing it
the way he I mean he was doing crowd
work in an arena in a way that was so
unique and and to figure that out in a
big venue like I like to do crowd work
in big venues just to mix up an hour
just so I'm not doing anything like he
gets all his bits through crowd work
yeah rock song and he was like and then
he saw him again he was like and then he
went up to him this is the story anyway
he goes because Rick and I got past the
comics with the same day wow that's cool
but then like he couldn't get anything
in the business yeah
um we're a failure Place yeah yeah and
he's hideous and
um and he was like eventually trying to
lift someone up here
[Music]
after the second or third time he saw me
because you always kill this well and
Rick's like yeah I I don't know yes
anyway see you Chris Rock yeah funny
answer yeah I do well no I'm a [__]
nobody cares about me I don't know how
to talk to fluke yeah and then
eventually he was like I want to go on
the road it's like all right wow he's
got to wear a suit he goes oh that's
good
because I don't have a suit and he goes
we're gonna get you was he in a suit
when you said yeah oh and you know
what's great about what he did was uh
Chappelle is late because his jet was
like not taken off or whatever so it was
just hilarious he cuts at that [__]
close yeah right
it was a brunch Ingram Ingram uh is
stretching with crowd work and it was I
was like this is pretty cool to watch
because I was with veter and James
because they're not there for that
they're not there for Rick Ingram no and
he went up after Rock doing this [__] to
stretch and he's doing well with that
wow this is pretty damn impressive and
we kind of were looking at each other
and I and I said to James you know who
does the road with me a lot directed my
last specialist directed Mark specials
Kansas City fan I said this is [__]
hard what she's doing right here he's
doing he is stretching in between Rock
and Chappelle with crowd work in an
arena and no one's heard of it no one's
heard it and he's killing he's
hey look at this guy and they put on a
job
is higher level than that no but it was
like but it was like but of course it
starts surface that's how you have to
start using the surface and then you
kind of ask questions and play off that
but yeah putting the guy on the screen
that's huge that's fine I mean because
if you're doing if you're doing it at a
club everyone can go oh who's that and
they can look and they can see them if
we're at The Comedy Store 160-seater you
can look over but I can see that yeah
yeah and then Arena you can't so putting
them on screen equals it out right yeah
income kills dude well good for him it's
good that he gets some shine finally
they're killing at the store for years
yeah I gotta respect people who pay
their dues and killing the clubs and and
then it's beautiful when you're just
ready for them and then Rock's like who
the [__] is this it's like some guy's
been crushing I love that apparently too
he's so bitter he's been so bitter for a
long time in a good way he's like [__]
that guy [__] that guy what do you know
like what are you like yeah we don't say
that out loud but we all agree you know
and so he would like tell
I don't know rock whoever's like hey
that joke's not good that people have
been doing oh he keeps it up all right
we'll do whatever and then after he gets
off because I told you dude that joke
because he's not trying to kiss up like
everything was great here maybe one
tagline he's like that's bad that's bad
and then Chris Rock I heard was like oh
finally I got a guy who's honest with me
ah interesting well let me say thank you
weird question are you in rock cool yet
I mean I've never been friends with him
but I don't know well you made up yeah
yeah
all right
I don't I don't know whatever well it's
new hours great
he's not a fan of mine we have a special
for the Chris Rock app we have a special
guest judge for this app already comes
into the cowboy hat you gotta love a
ghost see someone killing and uses them
rock is a [__] Legend of all the
celebrities he's one of the few ER rocks
Chappelle there's some guys are like I'm
just always going to be a stand-up and
other guy's like well I'm an actor now
I'll still try it once in a while
people ask me about anybody and it's
like oh no that's a real stand-up yeah
and I was talking to him at one point I
was like man it's just hard all these
[__] podcasts and all this radio and
all this press and all these other stuff
to keep writing jokes and like I'm gonna
do I do it but it's like man it takes a
lot out of you and he kind of looked at
me goes what else is there and when
Brock says that [__] to you what else is
there besides what stand up
wait what but the other thing is what
you were saying no but I'm saying it's
hard to write stand up oh when you have
this when you have so much other [__]
because you're just creatively Zapped
like this [__] does take it out of you
all the other stuff does take it out of
you and rock is saying what else is the
main thing and that's Jerry's uh you
know that's how Jerry looks at it that's
how like the great that's the main thing
the legend look at it yeah you know
where it all comes back even if they
didn't have the success they had
elsewhere they would be stand-ups they
would be obsessed with jokes and they
would be waking up every day in writing
and it's a reminder that like you know
even if it's not like the hip thing
content-wise always be writing new stand
up it is the most important [__]
thing yeah we're stand-ups at the end of
the day we do pause the other thing we
interviews videos clips but it's all the
problem is if you're doing a movie it's
like these are someone else's words I
don't care I'll just try to do as funny
as possible if you're doing podcasts
like I'm wasting my funny time I love my
my own funny time but it's a catch 78
because you wanna you wanna get them to
come see your stand up so it's a good
job but there is a little balance and a
certain point you've got it but it's
also like that's what a lot of people do
wrong where it's like I've got these
clips I've got I've got pockets like all
right but dude you're forgetting stand
up yeah you're acting I see a lot of
guys like that you're active suffering
don't forget stand up of course go up
five nights a week three times a night
stand up is so hard and they go this is
easy though I can talk or I can make a
video and clip it out and just like talk
about a a current event yeah yeah okay
great as a bonus exactly but like you
need promo [__] you need an act but an
act is hard and the problem is a lot of
these guys guys get paid a lot for their
podcast so they're like well that's my
focus now it's like oh yeah you're
[__] you're [__] you became a
podcast guy which is fine yeah it's a
great living and it's cool and you can
be still be funny but you're no longer
one of us it is at the end of the door
like or like you're not doing a service
like you're still in one of us but like
you're not giving enough time to this
exactly thank you that's something I
can't do it I like that we're talking
about the purity of stand up and Mark's
like hold on let me let me start all
right there I just [__] myself I just
took a note I like that that's where my
career is gone hold on hold on okay
you're like all-time favorite stand-ups
like back in the day like oh geez like
who do you like please say I don't care
for stand-up comedy oh he likes yeah I
love stand up but uh the first comedian
I ever got into was Brian Regan yeah
greatest then Nick Swardson was like my
team yeah I love swarty Nick is a
[__] great comic you look amazing
hands down amazing dude
my grandmother wouldn't watch it with me
but I tried to put it on with it because
you died in the Holocaust
I'm not a fan old Nazi um
she wouldn't even start it Christchurch
yeah yeah fat no fat
you guys are great all right all right
we were going for present company
excluded here present company
yeah he's one of the funniest guys
Reagan story me and DeVito I'm I'm
ramping up for my special Danny Danny
DeVito all right opening for me in
Kansas City you get a call from I think
Zimmerman
Joe yeah yeah I was like hey uh Brian it
was George Brian week wants to come to
your show tonight he's got an early show
he wants to come to your late show which
has been a dream for so [__] long
yeah I'm like how come on forget this
and he's like hey I'd love to show up
says hi before he goes I'm just sit in
the back and watch that's what he I've
always heard that story she sits and
watches the whole thing because you
wanna have some drinks after and I'm
like okay now I was sober at the time
because I'm like I'm trying to focus on
the special I'm not drinking DeVito at
the same time was also sober I'm not
drinking right now you've all been sober
we're like I'm taking for them you not
you have I'm taking a month off okay
you've not done that a month uh whatever
a week off whatever pregnant anyway we
were both sober and then but but [__]
Brian Regan Legend Regan wants to drink
everyone's Davido what do you want to do
he goes I I think we should drink I'm
like yeah
it wasn't sober October though was it it
was not thank God and we had just a few
drinks and it was so [__] cool to
hang out with this [__] he's the
coolest but we both are like your
stand-up is on such another level it
never gets the respect he does get the
respect
no he doesn't get labeled in the the
Mount Rushmore is a lot yeah
should one of the greatest he's supposed
to be on this twice but he had I think a
health thing we got him right get him
tequila oh [__] he's still on the phone
he's uh he came to my show with the
Irvine Improv once and how cool is it it
was pretty surreal and uh he's an
incredible guy that's right guy Beyond
being a great great top down when he
gets that like yeah and how many people
stole that by the way yep not stole it
but do it do it he's a he's a really
classy dude on top of being one of the
greats I mean yeah man I've told the
story a million times I'm bombing at the
Charlotte Comedy Zone there's 28 people
there it's a big room and one guy in the
back is going ah I was like well at
least I'm working with that guy whatever
it's him no yeah
whatever the [__] across the street and
I said he walked over there oh no it's
Dennis
[Laughter]
but yeah then we ended up drinking all
night and he is off stage he is not
clean which was also fun oh God rules no
he's a he's a really cool dude Good Egg
another thing happened his agent hit me
up and said hey can you open for Reagan
his his opener dropped out and I said
sure he goes just send me a video and I
was like oh my God so I sent him a Conan
because I wanted to send a clean clip
and it was a good clip but he goes whoa
what are you crazy we can't use it's
like gay jokes and sex jokes but it was
clean but you can't even have the the
subject matter well Conan's clean for us
yeah exactly for that crowd so he fired
me the ages and then a week later he
called me himself and was like hey man
I'm sorry about that that was none of
that was my idea I didn't mean to get
your hopes up that was a bad way to
handle it I was like oh my God knows
what it's like to be a comment yeah he
sent me a message during covid I guess
he was he's like
[Laughter]
when you're like down here you're like
it's Brian [__] Regan of course wow
can you imagine me the other way we're
writing some I heard somebody in raw dog
I'm like hey man I'm a big fan that was
like really funny like okay random dude
yeah no no I'm a comic right right oh I
know and he has stories of legendary
bombs which is so like they did it on my
show he did a story about it oh really
bombing at a NHL game wow Zamboni goes
out and they like made him go do a thing
for Bud Light or something ah I'm just
eating it crazy I think a guy that funny
he still you know had his he is like a
cartoon character funny oh yeah like the
way he manipulates his face and the way
yeah look at that like look at that
exactly like he's like Cartoon Level
funny man the one man on the moon is
that the special yeah holy [__] it's one
of the best specials all improv no at
The Improv all right but he did the
mullet for Theo sucking Theodore oh yeah
the mullet the mullet Theo that's early
yeah baby
man like are they gonna look back on our
outfits like that yes yes I mean it's
that outfit I eat Brian Regan I love you
I cannot defend this outfit wow like a
cowboy hat and a knit hat indoors it's
like yeah this is a podcast not a
special here yeah I'm wearing it for a
gag you guys okay the knit hats Jesus ah
it's a toque it's good a took
damn that guy rules yeah yeah you know
he bought that cream suit like man this
will never go out you guys gotta have
this guy on here well that's how we're
gonna look at bomber jackets yes sign a
lot called that bomber jackets are gonna
be like like what were they thinking and
they're called bomber it's all bad yeah
who gives a [__] you gotta try to be as
Timeless the [__] comes back that's the
thing it does come back you know what
era they're on right now because it's
like they went with the 70s 80s 90s I'll
come back really fast future they're
doing Jetsons now you see people that's
a fashion yeah she's doing futuristic
oh really Futures it was in between the
80s and 90s they did futuristic for a
little bit that's now back we got outro
here all right
deep cut bro wow I forgot about Elroy
how's the bus do you like it I love it
that's cool I'm gonna do one next winter
I love the bus I mean the tour bus it's
me Gary veter James who films and her
toy manager Brian and it's like a great
hang it's a it's we we're literally
pounding natural wine and Whiskey on the
bus wow watching Something About Mary
yeah
like I'm like this is good living and
then I just pass out in that little bunk
and I'm like this is
this is good living you I love if you're
Irish people buying your own tour bus
yes I'm going to the bathroom and like
where's sambin it's like oh he's asleep
we literally go to sleep laughing every
night that's the best thing about being
with people that get you we're cracking
up all night and then they should wake
up in Tucson we wake up in the next city
and the only bad thing is bring your
[__] allergy meds oh yeah uh
legendary
holy moly I don't care how elitist you
are a fart is always funny that was gold
that was the witching hour and that was
a good that was a good sound on your
phone Great Sound we talk about farce in
this pod like it's r b how did you get
that sound
like Berry Gordy
kid that's gonna be a hit your kids are
gonna love it
uh no but it's it's the best dude I love
it you would do it you're gonna do it
I've done the bus opening but uh I'm not
I don't know if I want to do the bus but
I talked to James Webb and veter like we
can't wait to get back home we had so
much fun I make sure everyone's having
fun at all I got it would be cool to do
it that way with your girl maybe or like
or or just like a bunch of comments and
just like have a the way we do the ski
trip or the burnt stuff it's like
let's have some fun with Comics let's
yeah we gotta hit we gotta do a steak
night or something yeah for sure we
gotta do a steak maybe that's the uh
maybe that's the bodega cat night who
knows this summer dude is gonna be the
summer of us yes bring back some of
Spritz
[__] Michelle wolf she ain't gonna be
here it's us let's get her back Michelle
wolf Michelle
she's living her best life in Spain
right now let her enjoy it take two
weeks off and come do summer Spritz with
Norman Morrell and shafir she knows
she's bored you want a Bud Light on I
think she's happy she messaged me the
other day she seems very happy all right
is she doing stand-up yeah oh okay okay
but she's doing stand-up where she's
like there's a lot of stage time here
and I'm like is there yeah exactly
there's the part of me I was like I know
you're happy but is there are there
really good expats is the Madrid scene
really good
but uh no we miss her we're just saying
that because we miss her and yeah dude I
love drinking with Michelle back in the
day like an all-time Boozer she was a
Tuesday she would go hard after all
spritzes too she turned us on to those
yeah it was Michelle wolf and Liz the
comedy seller would be pounding those
and then that made me and Ari pound
those you get to the point where I get
drunk and then I'd be like I would get a
spritz and I'd be like go up to the bar
like have done something wrong that you
would ignore an orange slice in this
if we have a problem let's talk about
this and Michelle's funny but after six
or seven she goes into like Pennsylvania
hairdresser like you're gonna die alone
you get red State and they drunk yeah
you get and you get deep Michelle drunk
you get Hershey Michelle Hershey squirts
yeah she goes in Hershey no kisses
big drink it really seems to care
well she got to do four sets drinking
the whole time and then by the end of
the night uh oh this kid just uh got a
new dad
this is what love is the paternity test
just came in Syracuse you were not the
father
I can't believe your wife okayed this
I've been drinking too much the other
day the doctor found an olive in my
urine sample I'll tell you I'm a drinker
is that a real joke okay I was like damn
that's good dude I'll tell you when
you're drunk you should write for him
when you pee in your pants
[Laughter]
that's just a real drug yeah I'll do
that to go what are you drinking oh
Jaeger you're gonna [__] yourself
for every drink oh my God a brilliant
way to end a show I know what a closer
oh man attella had that bit about uh you
know you're drunk when you [__] your
pants and uh and your pants aren't down
or something or something like just
because you're just because you uh are
drunk doesn't mean you're wearing a kilt
it was something like that oh yeah it
was such a weird great line what's your
favorite animal dog I like a horse
because you can [__] it then get a ride
home
yeah it's classic that's a great joke
everywhere I turn I get a drink have you
had him on here yeah once for about 45
minutes and he Zang the [__] out of it
he showed up it was cranky and it was
hilarious he's just looking around
though he just stood up and started
looking around and we go what's going on
he goes I'm just looking for some punch
lines oh my gosh we weren't getting
anything else like all right come in and
join him I said like what the heck I
think you say something like oh really
here's the subjects oh you're not funny
at all yeah I set you up do I not you
don't know what to do he's he is at what
point do you like Dave you're like all
right I don't know what I'm supposed to
say I know I know you're yelling at me
but that's the the beauty of a man like
those old those old school Comics are
such curmudgeons and and that's part of
what's so funny about curmudges Chris
Rock America
I like that the queen as we saw I saw
Quinn show last night Quinn show is
great great which words you're doing now
small talk is it the Lucio lortel
theater
phenomenal do you see it yet yeah I saw
it twice I heard he's Irish
and from Brooklyn oh yeah but a killer
show funny stuff I mean there was a
couple things we're like oh it's like
poignant where you're like oh [__] I
never thought of it that way I quoted so
many times I think rest say blue state
where he's like in the old days you just
get to talk with somebody about
something and it wasn't the end of
things you'd be like whoa oh yeah I bet
you're I bet you're in favor of gun
control you know as a matter of fact I
am ah let's get a drink
and that was the end of it well that's
the beauty of his social commentary it's
not polarizing it really is yes I'm
observing this from both of you he had
an abortion joke and I was like how's he
gonna get out of this one and it killed
it was such a neutral line but it was so
funny gun stuff he he finds a way to
really like an old school Entertainer
bring everyone yes and that's that's the
skill of an old school my favorite job I
don't want to give too much away Kyle
but I think my favorite joke in the
whole special was he's like the
president used to be like that's not
what we can do for you but what you can
do for your country and he's like now
the presidents that come out and go we
see you we love love you we notice you
can you imagine being in China and they
go hey the government noticed you oh
[__] oh yeah no he's uh rules he's the
best I asked him about like I was like
talking about like uh venues for my
special for Jew on YouTube right now
um five and a half mil pails in
comparison out to lunch and I got this i
got this
um
I was like hey have you ever what's your
the one he played I was like have you
ever done a flashlight immediately calls
me I won't forget the tax like hey yeah
what are you planning why okay should I
I'm not sure this will be the place for
you maybe try something else I love that
yeah
cares about stand-up when I got to New
York
who's new here
uh Norman and Liz wouldn't talk to me
um and I was just new here and I was at
the cellar not even the back table but
nearby and he he walked in and conquered
from SNL and like whatever else tough
crowd he walked in stopped and he goes
oh hey you're already shaffir right I
heard you're new here you're a good
comic uh welcome welcome to the scene I
hope you feel good here let me know if
you need wow I was like that was so
welcoming gee he told me he thought you
were a high me [__]
yeah
he did a similar thing to me when I was
new at the seller really yeah he like he
just sat down at the table I was there I
was brand new there I was a kid and he
was like he sat down next to me goes hey
Sam no like didn't even introduce just
like hey Sam look at the lineup yeah and
I was like and I've spoken other comics
and you do pay that forward I do yes oh
good Ronnie Chang said that he was like
I was just in Ronnie Chang oh really he
said that about you he's like I was in
town it's my first week here Sam made me
feel really comfortable out of nowhere
yeah you have so many stories of people
like hey are you working the cover with
the comic store I came in as a new comic
and I was like oh boy this could go one
of two ways you raped me and it really
does sometimes like you were such a [__]
other times like you were so welcoming
and I'm like so every time people break
it I'm like I don't know it's gonna go
either way I've only seen you be nice to
Young comics comics yeah yeah yeah not
basketball players who die no but Comics
these are incredible cocktails all great
drinks I mean this is a [__] blood
this is like I'm gonna have a great food
today at therapy very good sir
you killed it you really killed it yeah
we should wrap this up we've been here
for hours
Clancy Cameron Cameron I was born in
1843 my name
you look like Clancy
all right one that a Simpsons character
was Eric Clancy yeah the the police
friend police sir Clancy Clancy Williams
was it Clancy I believe so oh I love you
my favorite character The Simpsons was
myself do we have hangers
no way
so cool you guys are this big now I was
talking to the ayg guys today where it's
like people just reach out to you now to
be like yeah
it really seems to kick we got there all
right well Ari uh go see Ari at the
Beacon March
24th Beautiful Surprise guests we're
having a great time it's my [__]
Hometown show I'm gonna [__] blow it
out most of the floor seats are gone get
up [__] to the top but look at that
we got Ari's got Seattle Vancouver San
Jose Salt Lake City I'm at the whole
European tourism Glasgow London
Manchester Amsterdam Stockholm oh Berlin
I know yeah it's gonna be
um I can't pronounce the restaurant so
just go to his website
what is that going to visit the town my
dad got driven away from by the Nazis
for real content I'll give you money
uh Atlantic City Huntington New York uh
Royal Oak Michigan added there
Minneapolis we added Madison uh
Milwaukee New Haven Boston we're pretty
much fifth uh I don't know okay
why what's going on ski weekend oh I'm
sorry buddy uh Miami we're out in there
Orlando we're adding uh some Ponte vidre
some some [__] horseshit town in
Florida uh near Jacksonville we're
adding there Atlanta Charleston some
[__] norfolks Charlottesville right
yeah Norfolk Virginia D.C we added
Wilkes-Barre I said Wilkes bar last week
you guys [__] gave me [__] I
apologize I made a mistake get over it
Portchester New York Sam morrell.com
come out to Wilkes bar yeah hey who
cares about my day just come
March 17th and 18th to Chicago at the
Vic tickets on the website uh we added a
Friday show so let's uh let's get that
one sold out and then I'm all over the
road special man wrap it up a new
special Mark Norman awesome Netflix
special rocking Radia excited we're
cooking and we'll find a guy for the ski
trip maybe Jeremy Renner all right
happy to have you yeah thank you so much
Cameron you were great great bartender
I'm just done that's those three or you
got more
one more
not today but you interview more and we
might even get one or two more just in
there
guys I love you love you all right thank
you comedy Sunday
[Music]
and I get down in the same way
dangerous
I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
with my
body
[Music]